everything is mindset and everything is
pushing the limits and I've kind of been
shaped from a big loss in my family my
mom she passed away it was 4 and a half
years ago she passed away and I'm very
conscious of the fact that tomorrow is
not promised so I very much live that
way in every day of my life and that can
be it can be good and it can be bad but
I'm trying to squeeze as much out of
life through experience travel eating
nice food seeing interesting things as I
can and it might not as you say adhere
to the the typical ultr running space
but like my biggest asset I would say is
my mental space and when when gets
tough like that's when I'm really ready
to go so all those side things that I do
become irrelevant at the time when when
they need to be but it's everyone says
it and it's cliche but you don't know
what's happening tomorrow so please try
and please enjoy it